c'est non non nous allons maintenant
écouter la colère du peuple français par
la voix du procureur général de la
république des proches française
françaises français belle belge mon
président mon chien ma maîtresse ma
chienne gèrent très mousseurs américano
maniaque
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri mon amour l'amérique est l'ennemi
de la france dick rivers est l'ami de la
mairie or les amis de mes ennemis sont
mes ennemis donc dick rivers est
l'ennemi de la france donc je pense que
ce serait une assez bonne idée de lui
couper la tête
elle vous regarde tout ce que je
pourrais ajouter à cette démonstration
implacable serait superflu mais comme le
temps qui m'est imparti ne touche pas à
sa faim à lundi pour le superflu
en quoi l'amérique est l ennemi de la
france je vous en prie monsieur villers
je vous en prie je ne vous ai pas
interrompu alors je vous en prie ne me
coupait pas la parole jozan en fait ce
n'est pas toute l'amérique est notre
ennemi c'est l'anglo-saxon l'ennemi
héréditaire de notre patrie il y à 7 ans
je l' ai déjà dit ici même lors d'un
débat semblables sur france inter et je
sais que les françaises et les français
m'ont entendu et je le répète et je le
répète monsieur villers je ne vous ai
pas interrompue le temps perdu et il
faut que les françaises et les français
le sachent
je vous en prie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce n'est pas avec des propos aussi bas
que vous arriverez à me faire perdre mon
sang-froid l'anglo saxon est l'ennemi
héréditaire de la france et ce ne sont
pas mes camarades de l'ex division das
reich qui vont qui vous diront le
contraire
je ne suis pas rancunier vous le savez
mon président vous me devez un dîner la
coupole les 200 balles depuis six mois
maintenant à le kilo alex propres vous
m'avez piqué une de mes meilleures
femmes tous âges est oublié
c'était pas 220 c 220 me oubliant
oublions oublions je ne suis pas
rancunier mais quand même ce que les
anglais ont fait à jeanne d'arc
je ne suis pas prêt de l'oublier je
rappelle brièvement aux incultes qui
était jeanne d'arc
je le rappelle à l'intention des
musiciens et des chanteurs de rock et
des enfants débiles ou incultes de un
culte de cette époque que toute entière
marquée au sceau du laxisme et de la
permissivité pauvres petits enfants pour
qu'ils les grandes dates de l'histoire
de france sont la première apparition de
plastic bertrand emilie première le 14
juillet 277 et la puberté de mireille
mathieu 1956 1981
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous conseille cet égard la lecture
de passionnantes ouvrage de jean edern
[ __ ] qui vient de paraître
vient de paraître aux éditions vraie
jeune fille de france
le titre mireille mathieu at-elle vu le
loup qui pose sans détour la vraie
question que tout le monde se pose en
tout cas c'est pas moi j'aime pas le
boudin blanc
jeanne d'arc justement était plutôt par
lot de son vrai nom jeunes dit jeanne
d'arc dit jeanne d'arc naquit adoré me à
412 d'un père gardien de chèvres et
d'une mère communiste oui on n'est pas
sûr qu'il était communiste mais enfin
les des pauvres c'est déjà un début
je voudrais pas dire du mal des pauvres
mais il y en a quand même plus chez les
communistes que chez régine je sais ce
que je dis je sors énormément le père de
jeanne dit le berger dit la loi m'y
accrocher ne tarissait pas d'éloges sur
ses chèvres qui n'émet plus que de
raison d'où l'expression dithyrambiques
[Applaudissements]
il faut pas
il a
[Applaudissements]
jeudi fut surnommé jeanne d'arc
parce qu'elle faisait très bien le grand
écart jeanne est une enfance a do ré mi
fa sol facile elle jouait dans l'herbe
avec sa quenouille en faisant semblant
de garder les chèvres comme elle ne
s'enfonce est pratiquement jamais sa
quenouille dans les oreilles jeanne
n'était pas mal entendantes ce qui lui
permettait d'entendre des voix jeunes
qui sait c'est le premier kiss & tell
plombier d'autrefois quand elle avait
fumé trop d'herbe et l'entendait
d'autres voies jeunes jeunes jammot et
j'entends des jeunes oui tu parfaitement
que je souhaitais veine du obama mais
rejetées rosen que si le cinq jeunes
jeunes je suis là quand saint jean edern
jeunes les seniors et ordonne d'aller
bouter langlois hors du royaume est bien
bonne celle là je connais même pas votre
langue loi je vois pas pourquoi j'irais
velouté mais non c'est du vieux françois
mais quel but lensois quand je parle du
vieux françois je parle de la vieille
langue c'est ainsi que jeanne la bonne
lorraine bhutta les angloys de
l'orléanais et fit sacrer le dauphin
charles à reims en 14 129
elle avait 17 ans pourquoi l'appeler ton
la pucelle d'orléans
tout simplement parce qu'elle s'est fait
dépuceler aux aubrais
la scène la scène atroce de cruauté eu
lieu dans le cachot humide sordide plein
de rats sauvages de chaussettes noires
de vermine sans lumière sans rien sans
même un magnétoscope vhs ou les anglais
avaient enfermé jeune robert bresson ou
robert bresson robert masson à fort
intelligemment reconstituer ce cachot
dans son film le procès de jeanne d'arc
qu'on peut aller voir encore dans les
ciné clubs pour le prix d'un tube de
barbituriques
c'est avantageux le quart du film fait
autant d'effet qu'un tube entier de
barbituriques le procès de jeanne d'arc
un film de robert bresson
pas d'utilisation prolongée sans avis
médical un matin jeanne étaient en
prière dans son cachot sans moquette
sans rien quand la porte s'ouvrit dans
un grincement sinistre s'était l'évêque
cauchon georges conchon évêque de
beauvais vendue aux anglais ils étaient
fourbe côte le chafouin plus en
rédhibitoire
s'il est si maquiller qu'on aurait dit
le doyen de laisser les vivres aux
dossiers de l'écran
il s'approcha de jeanne en soufflant
comme un phoque son collier d'or très
sautant sur sa bedaine frottant ces
grosses pommes bagués l'une contre
l'autre
son oeil glauque luizet de lubricité
malsaine bien qu'il fût catholiques
pratiquants puisqu'il était avec
[Rires]
toi jane moi tarzan
moi tir à l'arc
moi c ghosn est en pilou pilou plutôt
joli jeu n'a pas le tien qu'un homme
voilà que le magicien la zigounette
télescopique et c'est ainsi que jeanne
péri par le feu car elle était sainte
certes mais pas unifiés j'ai alors dit
la mas dieu le 30 mai 14 131 me dit en
lançant vers le ciel malgré les flammes
qui l'entouraient ce merveilleux cri
d'amour trois mois jamais grâce at-elle
volatiles damas où nous les simples
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là la parole est à la défense métrage
darlan ne vous écoutant un petit peu
plus facile mon vieux procu gentil jury
mon beau rockeur m'ont dit que mon
bien-aimé doux trouve à deux et à voter
un grand baiser comment qu'est ce qu'on
me dit que vous accusez cet homme sur
coeur vous sourire simon occurred rue
est serré comme une poignée de blanc et
de quoi s'il vous plaît d'amel
d'amérique
dur à dire d'américanisme mais c'est
absurde mais c'est absurde
l'américain ça n'existait pas avant je
n'ai pas peur de le dire haut et fort
avant d'y qui l'amérique n'existait pas
alors je pose une question de couac est
on condamne mon client avant lui avant
d'y qui l'amérique on savait pas ce que
c'était
il en a fait une langue il en a fait un
pays un jour un jour comme ça qu'ils se
promenaient sur la croisette à nice avec
une fille qu'il avait beaucoup de mal à
séduire et on se demande pourquoi
à bout d'arguments il lâcha mais en fait
non qui ne peux pas me refuser si enfin
baby
encore une autre miss ont refait le mot
l'hommage juste de plaire vu le baby
huawei férial comme me dire oh baby le
coût du ma vie c'était une invention
géniale
et puis un jour tout de même au bout de
5 6 ans elles ont commencé à se lasser
les filles sur la croisette
elle tire guère voilà le mec a baby on
va rigoler je vais lui dire bonjour
elle jouera y baby
[Rires]
pauvres bêtes disait plus quoi inventer
effectivement pour s'en sortir il fallut
que le créateur crise très vive très
sincère les filles ça sert à faire créer
alors dit qu'il se mit dans un coin de
la jetée est reparu au bout de quelques
années
barbu et en haillons en hurlant j'ai
trouvé après bobby c'est dûment comique
rosie baby you may comique ghazi trait
de génie c'était la phonie nice connu
son premier raz-de-marée le casino
s'écroula hélas sans le mr qui aurait pu
aller avec de nouveaux nés qui pu
séduire au la gonzesse affichant ap
d'imaginer voir un jour n'y ait des
choses johnny il a pas la mode comme moi
je les belles jaune il a peut être pas
la mort de la meilleure cote r à hilla
le scoters unis il a peut-être le
scooter jeudi mais c'est pas lui qui le
dira babillements comique ghazi pardon
pardon je le ferais tout ce que tu
voudras tpr hamouma certains mob à je
sais pas poussinettes il faut dire
please
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire mais je
te dis bien volontiers tunisie qui
bécaud je suis trop beau elle et moi tu
me le redira et poussines est là chez
moi deux minutes tu veux bien
audi qui je fais rien capté mais et
voilà c'est par les femmes que rivers
s'est fait un nom sur la cote parce
qu'il le disait des mots bizarres que
personne ne comprenait parce qu'ils
portaient des boots pointus comme un
opinel et un régime de bananes sur la
tête
bientôt bientôt le fameux baby fit le
tour du monde
certains essayaient de limiter sans
succès by by you back microids un pauvre
type et un jour sûr de son succès il
enfourcha sa mob et puis toute la route
jusqu'à paris en répétant son grand
succès sur tous les tons arrivé dans la
capitale il cira ses bottes et sa banane
d'un noir d'ébène et le défi sa chaîne
la chaîne de sauce alex et la démarche
chaloupée et complètement vulgaire
garçons ils avisent à la première super
pp vachement bien mais est il dit bobby
watt ou b&you mais encore là à leweb non
mais bobbi vise l'accent et ses trois as
they do and baby baby
merci parce qu'ils ont des chèques
dickie ra longtemps dans les rues et au
matin entre dans son os mollet il eut la
révélation est muni du uss mais c'est
enfin corse au loft christophe colomb en
ville fallait qu'il parte
de là ils n'avaient plus qu'un pas à
faire qu'ils franchissent allégrement
avec l'argent de la vente de son solex
il s'achetait une caravelle et avec les
quelques vaillants guerriers qui lui
trouver il traversa l'atlantique
ce fut un dur moment dans sa vie de
desperados mais c'était bien fait pour
lui parce qu'il n'avait pas fait son
service militaire alors que je nie lui
avait au sco terre il avait fait il n'y
avait pas deux et à jour dans la
caravelle père terre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
10 qui avait rejoint les amériques
il hurla de joie aux chouettes les
armorigène l'attendait en foule sur le
quai de new york et 10 qui dans son
émotion pleura entendre bobby la foule
en délire connaissant un des siens
eurent la yole aqmi au mali
ghazi oui oui dit qu'ils étaient bien
chez lui
il resta quelques temps il décida de
s'installer définitivement il ouvrit une
laiterie changea son nom contre celui de
presley eu la chose plus la chance de
rencontrer antoine parmentier qui errait
ainsi cette pomme de terre à lapins et
finit ses jours tranquille entouré de sa
fille macha qu'il avait eu avec la femme
indienne de parmentier qui s'appelait
plateau va pas là bas elle vise
découvrit le rock
une sorte de cube qu'on met dans le
whisky
une boisson dru et serré comme une
poignée de hauts blancs et devint très
célèbre à cause de ça il grossit
beaucoup et mourut d'un éclatement dans
les années 70
laissons-nous d'en-cas pitois yépes à ce
pauvre m 2 août au bateau mon bien-aimé
mandic ou qui prétend être dick rivers
et libérons le cas je l'aurais s'est
bien défendu au fait les jeux bien
défendu c'est non non
[Musique]